vielen dank ich darf den anfang machen
unserer gruppe
unser projekt worum es heute geht ein
bisschen einen erfahrungsbericht
darstellen wollen zu boden
erfahrungsbericht aus den didaktischen
und theoretischen und
bildungspolitischen überlegungen aber
auch aus den ganz praktischen
erfahrungen im seminar kontext exaktes
manfred klasen szenario
ausgangspunkt unseres unserer
vorstellung des themas k untätig was wir
heute mal kurz hier präsentieren wollen
ist dass wir teil eines
forschungsprojektes sind dass es der
campus ein vom bmbf von der
bundesregierung im rahmen der
kriegsstrategie
geförderte plattform die zum ziel hat
die kompetenzen in der deutschen
bevölkerung denn ich jetzt mal zu
stärken das produkt ist kein spezifisch
universitären kontext sondern es ist die
breite der gesellschaft lebenslang
lernen wie es so schön beschrieben wird
aber auch schon durchaus schülerinnen
und schüler die der leichteren zugang zu
diesen themen haben das ist eine
maximale breite herangehensweise es soll
aber auch explizit in hochschulen
universitäts kontexte mit übertragen
werden und transformiert werden und da
haben wir hier an der lmu das den teil
der ki und entwicklers wissen das
einzige forschungsprojekt was sich
tendenziell gesamten breite zucchini und
ethik beschäftigt
dh wir haben sehr sehr sehr breite
thematische ausgangspunkte in bezug auf
unser forschungsprojekt aber das ist für
den heutigen zeit glaube ich erst gar
nicht so primär sondern eher sekundär
primär ganz kurz so was man die
strukturellen herausforderungen die wir
uns gedacht haben dabei bei diesem
projekt also das erste punkt ist wir
haben den kurs von anfang an als eine
doppelstruktur geplant das heißt wenn
man den kurs entwickelt 14 einheiten
auch so damit man das perfekt an dem
universitäres publikum übertragen kann
das heißt die eine reise die der kurs
nimmt ist eine einblendet format mit
einem verpassen was man in die
universitäre lehre integrieren kann das
heißt man bereitet sich zunächst im
flugblatt im szenario online vor und
kann es dann im rahmen von einem seminar
oder wie man das dann auch nennen möchte
auch transformieren die zweite
herangehensweise des kurses das zweite
ziel des kurses war auch dass das als
rein digitaler kurs absolviert da ist da
geht es jetzt vor allem nicht
universitäre lernen sondern da geht es
vor allem dann auch um die breite der
gesellschaft die diesen kurs auf dieser
plattform campus absolvieren möchte der
kurs hat eigentlich letzte woche
veröffentlicht werden sollen der campus
hängt aber noch ein bisschen nach weil
er es bisschen größer geworden wir
müssen sind fünf teile aufteilen
insofern in der nächsten woche soll er
dann veröffentlicht werden vielleicht
ganz kurz noch welche teile hatten wir
dort wir hatten dort
vier teile einmal diesen reinen online
kurs den wir uns dann ein bisschen
didaktisch genauer ansehen werden dann
der zweite teil habe ich gesagt das war
das flip glas und szenario wir später wo
mein kollege fabian heinzel noch ein
bisschen was dazu sagen wird und dann
hatten wir noch zwei weitere
bestandteile des eine waren podcast
podcast tripod den die fachschaft
philosophie
für dieses projekt mit hochgezogen hat
und den danach noch unabhängig vom
kontext fortführen wird und das wird es
im element waren ich nenne jetzt mal
software
anwendungen die von dem software
entwickler hier im aus dem münchner raum
programmiert wurden um quasi ihren ki
und ethik konfliktfällen bei der
software programmierung oder anwendung
sehr eben instruktiv darstellen zu
können
wir sind heute nur zu führt nicht zu
fünft und zwar aus den
unterschiedlichsten fakultäten aber alle
mit in gewisse anbindung an die
philosophische fakultät dass unser
kollege kann heute leider nicht da sein
deswegen gebe ich erst zum nächsten leer
antoni ab die noch ein bisschen was zu
den medien die taktischen grundlagen
sagen wird danach fragt nach fabian
heinzel der uns die best practice
beispielen philip glass
erläutern wird und dann kommt sarah
königsberger die uns mal das feedback
das wir von den studierenden aber auch
von krieg karten bekommen ein bisschen
dastehen wird so leer ich davon dich
abgeben
timo
vorweg noch mal vielleicht die
ungewöhnlichkeit auch die zusammenarbeit
im bereich der philosophie zu
verdeutlichen für uns das herkömmliche
rettung vor augen also den lektüre kurs
als wesentliches format in der
hochschullehre wir haben philosophische
texte und anschluss kommunikation und
sinne von diskussionen dann enthalten
aktiven den status von leitmedien anders
ist es schon im schulischen philosophie
und ethik unterricht der verstärkt auch
rechtlich sei das musizieren mit bildern
und filmen mit kinder- und
jugendliteratur oder auch theatralisch
sofia
der onlinekurs hier untätig umfasst eine
große bandbreite an lerninhalten
aufzeichnung dritten kapitel nämlich aus
dem bereich meetings normative ethik und
angewandte ethik wie auch eine
grundlegende einführung in konzepte
künstlicher intelligenz
wir haben einen
kompetenzorientierten ansatz gewählt so
dass es eine übertragung der kenntnisse
und fähigkeiten über die im kurs
erarbeiteten kontexte hinaus möglich
sein sollen
in speziellen solchen gefieder
philosophische kompetenten gefördert
werden die restlichen kompetenz
delegations kompetenz die urteils
kompetenzen und die handlungskompetenz
eine lernen theoretische grundlage die
in der konstruktion eine umsetzung des
online kurs berücksichtigung gefunden
hat das nicht nur so genannte
modell nachts und mein
mann ist ein akronym einkauf in
umgekehrter reihenfolge bestimmte von
außen beobachtbare lernaktivitäten steht
nämlich einmal verpasst wie wlan
aktivitäten
paradigmatisch wäre etwa zu hören einen
text lesen oder ein video ansehen
dann aktive lernaktivitäten
sodass sie markieren oder lücken auf 5
konstruktiv strukturieren gingen
beziehung setzen bis hin zum
interaktiven
diskutieren fragen stellen beantworten
vielleicht wird ja auch schon deutlich
dass auch im unterschied zu anderen
vorträgen etwas andere begriff von
interaktivität verwendet wird als einer
der wirklich auf interaktive
auseinandersetzung kommunikation
zwischen personen und nicht zwischen
lernen software abzielt
und für dieses modell konnte empirisch
gezeigt werden das
interaktive und konstruktive jahren
aktivitäten in partien und aktiven im
hinblick auf den lernerfolg überlegen
sind und zwar giftig insbesondere
hinsichtlich
kompetenzerwerb und lesefähigkeit
dementsprechend haben wir uns bemüht
interaktive und konstruktive
lernaktivitäten in form von impulsen und
aufgabenstellungen im online kurs zu
integrieren
hier ist was für die kursentwicklung und
auch die vibrationen im nachhinein war
und ist doch schon gar die rheinbahn
schrieben dreieck wissenschaftlich
science
dass alle die jetzt die materiale die
portale und geht soziale seite eines
lernen auch noch gleichermaßen im blick
nimmt und
entlang die für drei dimensionen der
vermittlung der aktivierung und
betreuung lassen sich viele verschiedene
didaktische prinzipien und aspekte
vororten
diese sammlung versteht sich als
abgeschlossen oder vollständig ganz so
gar nicht so stellt erst mal meinen
persönlichen besuch da
eigentlich diejenigen aspekte die wir
bei der kursentwicklung besonders
[Musik]
berücksichtigt haben und das auch
umgesetzt haben so zumindest um unser
eindruck ich werde nicht auf alles
eingehen dafür beispielsweise können
dass ich ihr zu lernen auch bereiten
unsere partner gucken of six
programmiert für den kurs lernen
anwendungen mit simulations- moment also
zum beispiel sollen sie lernen wenn eine
software zur sortierung von bewerbungen
trainieren und sie erfahren dabei geht
ich eigene auch im bewusstsein
voreinstellungen als zwei jetzt einem
algorithmus
niederschlagen
die strukturierung was den aufbau
angelangt folgen die lektionen innerhalb
der kapitel diesem thema beziehung
variieren auch
in eine einführung werden lernen viel
transparent gemacht
stichwort voreinstellungen hier kommt
zum beispiel das hafenfest und christa
anwendung ist darum funktioniert das
lernen re gegenüber bestimmten vornamen
zustimmung oder ablehnung per klick
häusern und so also noch vor der
einführung der jeweiligen theorie
basierten inhalte aktiviert und abgeholt
werden
zu den folgen gefunden sie möchte ich
gleich mit einem blick in die medien die
das geschäft gestaltung sagt nutzen
darbietung erfolgt im wesentlichen
zwei mal über innere friede videos von
expertinnen und experten
aber auch über ich nenne die
präsentation haben vier anwendungen die
also nicht primär übung oder
wiederholung ihnen um dann mit hp ist
auch viele möglichen bereiche treffen
verfügen und sie geriet timeline
aber natürlich schaffen wir auch offen
für anwendungen mit automatisiertem
feedback auf die wiederholung ziehen
auch somit auf anwendungen und
schließlich ein wichtiger bestandteil
zum stichwort interaktivität wie foren
reflexion aufgaben werden also bereit
gestellt und zur bearbeitung in foren
damit möchte ich übergeben fabian heil
jetzt erläutern wird dieser onlinekurs
zusammenspiel mit der
gedanke
ich werde jetzt ein ganz kurz einmal
noch mal durch das konzept philip glass
vom führen also es ist letztlich ein
konzept das mal anfängt der 2000 auf
schlecht ist die 2010er relativ
gibt mal wenn man der blended learning
sozusagen mit dem aufschwung der
digitalisierung immer mehr favorisiert
hat gibt aber so sagen dass heute viele
missverständnisse was sich dahinter
eigentlich verbirgt und deswegen
sozusagen noch mal kurzen überblick für
sie zumal das konzept jetzt gerade in
zeiten von corona und digitaler wäre
auch wieder ein bisschen aufschwung
erfahren hat also was wir letztendlich
darunter verstehen ist eigentlich jeder
name schon sagt eine umkehrung des
traditionellen unterrichts prinzips also
sehr arbeiten sozusagen die neuen
inhalte nicht primär in der sitzung und
üben die dann zu hause wie es jetzt
beispielsweise in der schule meistens
der fall ist oder auch eine universität
in der lehre sondern das ganze läuft
umgekehrt sie erarbeiten sozusagen neue
inhalte selbstständig zu hause und die
üben sie dann in der gemeinsamen sitzung
und vertiefen die noch mal vor allem im
hinblick auf die kompetenzen dass die
ihre konten patents strukturen sozusagen
auch praktisch ausbilden und haben dann
eben im nachhinein zu hause wieder die
möglichkeit reflektieren und wieder die
neuen inhalte für die nächste sitzung zu
erarbeiten was im clip classroom sehr
wichtig ist dass dadurch das ist ja
sozusagen ins blended learning
integriert ist
wäre es jetzt sozusagen kein klassisches
mit glas von dass die leute einen text
nach hause gehen und sagen da steht
alles neue trainer arbeitet das mal
sondern es wird in der regel mit hilfe
von video impulsen der digitalen
inhalten erarbeitet und diese gerade
schon gesehen haben lief das bei uns vor
allem über den campus über diese
plattform
lehre noch einmal ganz kurz weitergehen
würde
und wie sehr auch gab schon gesehen
haben im ipad modell haben wir sozusagen
hier ganz wichtige bausteine dh sie
haben also einmal die vorbereitungsphase
also das aktive wo sie sozusagen
aufgaben ausführen aber auch sich
vielleicht notizen machen einfach
selbstständig mit den inhalten
interagieren sich die aufbereiten und
auch passiv über unsere videos das ganze
anhören und was dann sozusagen in den
gemeinsamen unterricht fällt er sich den
die eigentlich vorbereitungsphase es vor
allem der interaktive und konstruktive
park wo bald schon darauf geachtet haben
gerade in diesen konstruktiven part also
noch mal sachen eine eigene worte zu
fassen auch zu vergleichen so cent
agieren dadurch dass wir gewisse
aufgaben begleitet übrigen hatten um das
eben nicht sozusagen interaktion und
eben konstruktive anwendungen im seminar
zu packen weil es oftmals sage ich mal
man denkt man da einen haben stunden
aber die zeit schneller um als man
schauen kann deswegen des sozialen vor
allem dieser interaktive bad gehen sie
zwar teilweise auslagern können die
waren aber doch nicht ganz ersetzen
können der eigentlich zentrale für unser
seminar genau und auch der nächsten
folie
würde ich ihnen noch mal ganz kurz zu
sagen jetzt nicht überwältigen lassen
wird so schön einfach die allgemeine
struktur sich mit ziemlicher auf ein
modell von loan to you die sozusagen ein
flip glas zum modell für wird speziell
die mathematik in dem fall auf
geworfen haben und sich dabei aber auch
verschiedene fallbeispiele bezogen haben
wir es im grunde meta-analyse und daraus
gesehen haben dass ein sag ich mal sehr
effektives flip classroom szenario
eigentlich dadurch ausgeprägt ist dass
sie eben zu hause diese videos haben
also in dem autos class szenario und
sich nebenbei im besten fall notizen
machen aufzeichnungen machen aber auch
begleiten würden eben in form
beispielsweise von chris aufgaben haben
und was dann in der innen phase sonst
passiert ist dass sie am anfang
natürlich die möglichkeit anbieten
müssen dass studierende fragen stellen
können wir natürlich nicht immer gleich
alles klar ist und erarbeitung phase
das sollte sozusagen am anfang stehen
sie haben dann aber natürlich die
notwendigkeit und auch die möglichkeit
dieses wissen aufzubereiten und
praktisch anzuwenden und ich werde ihn
gleich sagen wie wir das gemacht haben
aber es kann beispielsweise über
kurzvorträge laufen das kann auch über
individuelle über laufen über
gruppenaktivitäten ganz wichtig am ende
natürlich immer was auch danach getestet
wird die gemeinsam mit zusammen passen
auch die reflexion des gelernten damit
sie es auch festigen kann
ganz wichtig was auch sehr oft deswegen
habe ich unten nochmal hingeschrieben
auch falsch gemacht wird also ein trip
glas nun läuft in der regel nicht so
dass sie sich hinsetzen zu hause wird
das ganze arbeit und sie sagen das ganze
dann noch mal dadurch laufen sie
eigentlich dem konzept konträr sondern
sie sollten eigentlich das ganze üben
also zu vermeiden letztendlich diesen
input zu lange zu wiederholen auch ganz
wichtig wie die studien zeigen ist es
notwendig dass sie sozusagen nicht nur
die videos anbieten sondern auch eine
begleitung durch aufgaben und moderation
haben als sie müssen sozusagen eine
anwendung auch in der bearbeitungs phase
anbieten aber gleichzeitig auch die
möglichkeit dass die studierenden mit
ihnen in kontakt treten können und was
auch relativ wichtig ist die
abwechslungsreiche gestaltung in der
arbeit in der arbeitsphase im seminar in
der präsenzphase wo sieht man auch den
fokus auf die eigene übung leben sollten
und ich zeige ihnen jetzt sozusagen eine
analogie zu diesem modell ganz kurz wir
das umgesetzt haben ich will jetzt nicht
groß mit philosophischen kompetenz
modellen überfordern aber ich glaube sie
alle können relativ gut auch wenn sie
philosophisch zu sagen jetzt nicht
wissenschaftlich folge bildet sind
wahrscheinlich nachricht sind dass sie
in der philosophie drei dingen ganz
essenziell brauchen vor allem an
studierende das sind einmal methoden
also müssen sich sozusagen inhalte über
lektüre arbeiten können über quellen zu
müssen in der lage sein argumente zu
bilden und zu urteilen und auch
sozusagen nicht nur eigene argumente zu
bilden sondern auch fremde zu
analysieren und abzuwägen und sind
müssen letztendlich natürlich auch in
den dialog mit anderen treten können wir
so zeigen die philosophie jetzt nicht
wie man auch denkt im elfenbeinturm
geschieht sondern durch den gemeinsamen
austausch von inhalten
und sozusagen in
diesen rahmen haben wir in unserer auf
phase heben die videos e campus
angeboten da hatten die studierenden
sozusagen jetzt nicht die pflicht aber
die möglichkeit zum ist schrift wir
haben übungen interaktive inhalte
angeboten und auch ein forum zum
austausch das eben begleitet wurde durch
unsere moderation und sozusagen jetzt
das wesentliche die phase im seminar war
natürlich wie ich gerade schon gesagt am
anfang immer sehr wichtig die gemeinsame
besprechungen was eigentlich zu hause
passiert ist und dann jetzt eigentlich
der interessante teil wie haben wir die
verschiedenen arbeitsphasen gestaltet da
hatten wir zum einen eben nochmal
manchmal impulse über kurzvorträge
hatten auch gastdozent er zum beispiel
die darüber liegen der ein- zweimal dazu
gekommen ist und eben noch mal
seine persönlichen standpunkt in bezug
auf die seminare oder auf diese
zugegeben hat aber auch sogenannte
experten runden also dass es auch so zu
sagen weil wir viel reduzieren da waren
insgesamt auch unter uns selbst passiert
dass zum beispiel herr krieger oder
herunter damit leider nicht da es wenn
die besonderen tieren besonders versiert
sind sich dazu ausgetauscht haben und
auch durchaus gegeneinander argumentiert
haben weil sie so natürlich genau die
möglichkeit haben für studierende
unterschiedliche standpunkte und
argumente zu betrachten die zu
analysieren und dann auch abzuwägen
was wir auch sehr viel gemacht haben da
einen bezug auf die methodenkompetenz
ist die individuelle übungen eben durch
lektüre also dass gehabt mir sowohl vom
von ad hoc lektüren dass wir eben in
form von kurztexten im seminar gelesen
haben aber auch manchmal eine doppelte
lektüre also texte wurden schon zu hause
aufgegeben und vorbereitet dann aber
noch mal gemeinsam erarbeitet da wurden
inhalte präsentiert wir hatten auch ganz
sozusagen strenge debatten wo hohen
kontrasten zugeordnet wurden um eben
auch zu lernen verschiedenen
blickwinkeln perspektiven einzunehmen
und eben ganz klassische diskussionen
und dann auch die arbeit in kleingruppen
und breakout sessions wo wir teilweise
angeleitet haben also unter unserer
aufsicht sozusagen und hilfestellung
angeboten haben das teilweise auch
bewusst darauf verzichtet haben und die
studierenden letztendlich sich selbst
überlassen haben
und sozusagen in diesem zusammenspiel
eigentlich sehr gut beobachten konnten
wie sich diese verschiedenen teil
kompetenzen also gerade in hinblick eben
auf lektüre und analyse unter zeitdruck
sehr schön eigentlich über seminar
verbessert haben des öfteren und auch
wir zumindest beobachten können von den
studierenden sie aber auf das problem
bei kompetenz mit der performance
messung aber sehr gut beobachten können
dass gerade im rahmen des seminars da
bei vielen studierenden mit der zeit
auch eine gewisse konvergenz eingesetzt
hat dass man eben gesehen hat da wächst
das vertrauen sich auch in die
diskussion zu begeben und miteinander
auszutauschen
und geben auch die begleitung durch uns
assoziieren de wo wir uns aber sozusagen
nicht das klassisch immer vortragende
verstehen oder als diejenigen die neuen
inhalt mitteilen sondern eben als
begleitung bewusst als begleitung um den
studierenden eben in diesem rahmen zu
ermöglichen unter aufsicht sich selbst
ständig weiter zu entwickeln und auch
ihre eigenen kompetenzen sie eben
brauchen als zu früheren stücke
philosophin und philosophen trainieren
zu können
genauso viel zu mir und ich gebe dann
sozusagen passenderweise an meine
kollegen die frau königsberger die
nochmal aus der studentischen seite das
feedback mitteilen kann ob ich sozusagen
da auch richtig liege dass wir glaube
ich manches ganz gut gemacht haben genau
sagt er gern an der vielen dank fabian
genau was ich komme jetzt zu dem
studentischen feedback also erst mal
woher kommt dieses feedback wir haben
drei erhebungen gemacht einmal eine
moodle evolution damit vor allem
spezielle fragen bezüglich unseres
online kurs gestellt daran gibt es die
basis standard regulation von der
fakultät die fragen und sich besonders
auf die seminargestaltung zogen und in
einer seminar sitzung haben wir dann
zirka mitte des semesters auch noch mal
die studierenden persönlich nach
feedback gefragt wenn du weiter machen
kannst perfekt ich komme jetzt erst zum
feedback zum campus online kurs und dann
zum feedback zur seminargestaltung
also das feedback zum campus online kurs
vielleicht erstmals orientierungen wie
viel zeit haben die studierenden jede
woche auf dem campus verbrauch zu formen
zur nachbereitung da wurde im
durchschnitt 80 minuten angegeben das
war mehr als wir kalkuliert hatten wir
haben über 20 bis 25 minuten
projektionen angedacht und drei
lektionen meistens aufgegeben
andererseits wurde der arbeitsaufwand
von der mehrzahl der studierenden als
angemessen bewertet es gab nur eine
person die ihn zu hoch fand und drei
fanden ihn sogar zu niedrig
dann bezüglich der medien didaktischen
elemente im campus kurs die mit den
medien die praktischen elemente der als
am hilfreichsten bewertet wurden waren
mit abstand die videos der dozierenden
dann kam linke videos und dann erst
aufgabentypen bmc oder es zu fragen die
sich auf die videos bezogen haben und
als am wenigsten hilfreich wurden vor
allem aufgaben bewertet wie markieren
von wörtern im text oder freitext
aufgaben ohne lösungsvorschlag oder
interaktive bilder oder auch lückentexte
ein mediendidaktik element möchte ich
noch heraus greifen nämlich die forums
diskussions aufgaben die wurden
einerseits lotte moodle umfrage als
mittelmäßig hilfreich bewertet und das
haben sich meistens auch nicht sehr
viele studierende waren beteiligt
andererseits gab es das schriftliche
feedback das meer forums diskussionen
hilfreich wären vor allem deswegen da
zukünftig der kurs ja auch von personen
absolviert wird die die möglichkeit des
austausches in einem seminar nicht haben
und das haben auch bereits umgesetzt und
noch mehr forums diskussionen eingebaut
also insgesamt kann man viel feedback
zum campus kurs sagen dass es so scheint
das am meisten von den videos profitiert
wurde und dass die aufgaben abgesehen
von reflexion aufgaben teils als zu
einfach fürchte die philosophie
studieren de empfunden wurden
andererseits gab es aber auch das
feedback von einigen studierenden dass
sie die aufgaben hilfreich fanden
dadurch die inhalte der videos noch
einmal aufbereitet wurden und so wie
jemand geschrieben hat der merck faktor
größer war
und jetzt komme ich zum feedback zum
seminar also zum seminarkonzept und vor
allem zum länder learning und zum philip
glass von also generell wurden blended
learning und für classroom sehr positiv
aufgenommen und als gelungen bewertet
aber dennoch gab es zwei kritikpunkte
nämlich erstens dass es einfach noch zu
viel wissensvermittlung teilweise in der
seminar sitzung stattfand also es hätte
noch mehr darauf geachtet werden müssen
von anfang an dass in der sitzung im
fokus strikt auf der diskussion liegt
und keine neue wissensvermittlung und
auch nicht zu viele wiederholungen
stattfindet weil das sonst die sitzung
einfach zu viel macht und auf kosten der
diskussions zeit geht
das war für uns mit dem philip glass
natürlich erstmal meine auch eine
umstellung aber eben ich hatte auch das
gefühl dass wir da im laufe des
semesters da sehr viel besser geworden
sind
und der zweite punkt der genannt wurde
war dass sich manche studierende noch
eine noch engere verzahnung zwischen den
online lerneinheiten und dem seminar
sitzungen gewünscht hätten speziell
wurde angemerkt dass die studierenden
davor wissen sollten also vor dem
seminar sitzungen listen sollten welche
inhalte auf dem campus dann im seminar
diskutiert werden da ist nämlich sonst
sein kann dass manche studierende nicht
vorbereitet sind und auch nicht
mitdiskutieren können
dann auf die frage hin was den
studierenden besonders gut gefallen hat
und wovon sie am meisten profitiert
haben wurde mit abstand am meisten
geantwortet
dass die diskussionen am besten waren
die diskussionen sowohl in breakout
sessions als auch im plenum und der fakt
dass es mehrere sie ende gar wie auch
gastredner die eben verschiedene
blickwinkel und expertisen mitbrachten
und somit die diskussionen bereichern
konnten also insgesamt kann man sagen
dass er keine campus kurs und vor allem
eben die videos auch sehr gut
aufgenommen wurden und trotz einer hohen
teilnehmerzahl werden meistens und 30
studierende wurde eben in der seminar
sitzung fiel und lebhaft diskutiert und
im blended learning und niklas warum
haben eben auch soweit gut funktioniert
auch eben wenn es am anfang noch zuviel
wissensvermittlung stattfand genau also
das war das studentische feedback und
dann würde ich wieder zurück an die
träger übergeben
ja vielen dank
ich hoffe wir konnten jetzt in diesem
kurzen überblick nach bis hin zu unserer
erfahrungen aus diesem projekt in die
runde mit geben ich will ganz zum
schluss nur noch drei anmerkungen machen
die erste anmerkung wäre an dieser
stelle dass wir uns dafür entschieden
haben weil wir denken dass das sehr
sinnvoll ist dass wir noch eine
interessierenden leitfaden machen vor
dem hintergrund dass geplant werden soll
dass dir dieser kurs hier auch auf dem
campus online steht und dann auch in
weitere hochschul kontexte und das
zusätzlich nur dem bus und dann auch
eigentlich deutschlandweit implementiert
werden kann wo es auch schon
insbesondere von fachhochschulen
rückfragen dazu gab
und der zweite punkt wäre an dieser
stelle das schließt sich nahtlos an
diesen patienten leitfaden an dass wir
die erfahrung gemacht haben dass sich
blende das heißt die verknüpfung von
digital und ein analoger klassischer
lehre
definitiv rentiert und eigentlich dass
jetzt eine vermutung wir wissen noch
nicht wie es rein online abläuft aber
den bildungserfolg massiv gefördert hat
dass wir dieses klasse klassen hatten
sich auch aus den rückmeldungen dieser
art vorgetragen kann speist das führt
auch ein bisschen zu dem punkt
digital ist immer besser das kann man
eigentlich vor dem hintergrund sagen
dass digital nicht definitiv nicht
besser ist sondern auch das feedback
mehr da schon auch sie auf gewesen dass
es unter anbetracht der umstände ganz
nett war ganz gut war und dass es mit
sicherheit auch interessantes projekt
war und als ergänzung mit sicherheit
sehr viel potenzial hat aber es
klassische lehre am universitäts kontext
definitiv nicht ersetzen kann insofern
digital ist immer besser diese bekannte
spruch im zeit hoffentlich auch aus
prozenten perspektive sagen nicht für
die universitäre leere und zu guter
schluss
weil jetzt den ganzen tag schon ein
bisschen so dargelegt wurde sollte jeder
produzierende einen solchen kurs
produzieren möglichst viele digitale
methoden abbilden ich kann ihnen jetzt
mal nur so als haus noch mal sagen was
so ein kurs inklusive
opportunitätskosten freiwilligen
engagement und so weiter und so fort
kosteten über eineinhalb jahre sprechen
wir von dem kostenrahmen
ungefähr 200.000 euro das führt dazu
dass das eigentlich universität und
jemand als dozierende an sich selbst so
schwer stemmen kann und ich meine dass
hinter den bildung an sich auch schon
sehr bekannt dass man wenn man
beispielsweise die videos von microns
handle deren hervorragender rhetoriker
ist ein hervorragender film so ist das
mir vielleicht noch solche inhalte die
bereits bestehen zurückgreift und nicht
jeder sein eigenes süppchen kocht ich
denke wir hatten ganz glück dass wir
einige gute redner in den videos hatten
sowohl vom fachlichen als auch von
militärischen und dass wir sehr viel
engagement in die aufbereitung des
campus investiert haben so dass es uns
ganz gut gelungen ist aber ich glaube
nicht dass die zukunft für uns
dozierende sein wird dass jeder so
onlinekurse bargeld sondern dass das er
nur ergänzend und vielleicht bestehende
dinge schon in die lehre implementiert
werden sollen okay das fest von uns
vielen dank weil sie noch fragen und
diskussionen gerne